bei der hitze wünschen sich ja viele
eine abkühlung doch jahr zwei junge
fahrer haben jetzt eine unerwartete
abschluss bekommen mit ihrem auto sind
sie in nordrhein westfalen ein kanal
gestürzt
großalarm in recke im kreis steinfurt in
energie
die feuerwehr ist aus dem häuschen ein
auto steckt im kanal und jetzt mein
körper ist stocksauer
ich bin stocksauer also wirklich ich
kann das nicht honorieren nicht so ein
scheiß verhalten der stadt will dass ich
das jetzt sagen muss aber was ist hier
passiert auch die männer der feuerwehr
sind zunächst ratlos wie kommt der audi
in den kanal jasmin höcker hat alles
ganz genau beobachtet ja also ich wollte
eigentlich schwimmen den war auch schon
zum teil im wasser und ich habe nur noch
gesehen da war heute auch noch eine
gruppe junger leute und dann kam
plötzlich ein auto schon mit einem
affenzahn in die richtung ich dachte ich
habe mir da ich schon mal gedacht da
passiert irgendwas und ich habe mir
schon gedacht motorschaden oder so das
wäre echt perfekt ist das unterrichten
und dann habe ich zu meinem freund
gesagt welche der pflicht gleich ins
wasser kam er wieder zurück mit einem
affenzahn aber diesmal schneller bremst
paar meter vor der gruppe da ab konnten
schleudern ab ins wasser
überschlägt sich auch nochmal immerhin
verletzt wurde niemand aber der wagen
ist hinüber und es mit höcker
fassungslos ganz ehrlich das ist so
hirnlos warum man überhaupt in einem
kanal mit einem auto hier mit dem
affenzahn man ja eigentlich nicht helfen
darf das trotzdem macht ich meine da ist
ja nichts passiert aber selbst schuld
tut mir leid